hey alexander catch here in this title
tuesday video we're not going to be
going over this week's data set
instead i wanted to work on a different
type of project
um most of these videos are about like
machine learning and stuff like that but
i thought it'd be an interesting video
to do a riddler problem which
david robinson has done before um
basically
since it's getting to the end of the
year i wanted to start working on my own
r skills and one of the things i want to
work on is basically writing
it's more efficient code and i was kind
of wondering like how can i actually
practice writing faster code and
figuring out like where my bottlenecks
are at
and i think that doing these types of
riddler questions
is a good way to kind of like look at
how you can speed up your code
and also ways to just kind of approach
different problems
uh so i figured this would be a good
video to do
a rotor problem especially since i think
this riddler uh question is pretty
straightforward
it's the riddler express um from
december 4th
uh so i figured we'd make a video and
kind of see how we would approach this
i'm just going to copy on this text
and i'm going to go to in our studio
i'm gonna load in our markdown and i'm
gonna call this tidy
tuesday um riddler
i'll say december because i might do
more regular projects in the future
okay and i think for this video i'm
probably just only going to use the tidy
verse
i'm just going to load in the uh teddy
verse
and i'm going to put paste this um
the actual uh question in the into the
uh
uh the the script so from this
is from christopher halverson from a
bibliography bibliographic
bibliophilic bibliophilic game of secret
santa i have no idea what that word
actually means
so okay every year cj's family of five
including cj
so i guess five people do a book
exchange for christmas
first each person puts their name in a
hat that has shaken
and then each person draws a random name
from the hat and gives that person a
book
okay so it's kind of like a secret santa
thing uh
however if anyone draws their own name
they all put their names back
into the hat and start over what is the
probability that no one will draw their
own name
okay so i think this this is a pretty
interesting
um question because i think it's the
actual function that we'll use is gonna
be
pretty straightforward so since we have
like
five people so five people and basically
we're having something where it's like
we're sampling without replacement uh
because that one
when someone picks a
name from the hat it reduces the four
available names and the next person does
it and the next person does it etc until
there's no name and what basically we're
trying to do is
calculate the probability that no one
will draw their own name
okay so let's actually do this where i'm
going to just use the sample
function and with the sample function we
can enter in
five times of size equals five and we
just specify
replace is equal to false
so it's sampling without replacement and
then we can see it's three two one four
five
all right so out of the five names we
sent we uh we basically sampled it
five times without replacement so we
would expect to get all of the five
names
what i'm actually gonna do is i'm gonna
use these like numbers like three two
one four one two three four five
as like pseudo names right so one could
be jerry two could be
joe etc and what i'll just say is
uh if the first person is one
they're gonna go up and they drew three
the second person came up they drew a
two
since uh the second person drew a two
we'll just say that he
or she uh drew
his or her own name and that would be a
fail
right so how can we actually calculate
the probabilities that no one will draw
their own name
well this could be just one game right
here so this would be basically a fail
uh and i think what we could do is just
read basically use this function
and just reiterate it multiple times and
then calculate the probability
using like the law of large numbers okay
so one thing that we have to do
is think of this as how we can write
this in a very fast efficient
uh code because right now this is
actually very fast because it's
vectorized and it's a base our code so
right now we're saying like oh
we drew it we do it again i just
simulated like three times
uh but we need to check if these numbers
match their indices
and how we can do that is we can
actually do the equals
oops is we just say okay so this
this sample right here is equal to
i want to say one two three four five
right so we have false false true false
false i'm actually going to first do
this as a test so i'll say
first run right so that way we can just
kind of like
make sure it's not um changing all the
time so we have our first run
a two three one five four and then we
can just
check if they drew their own name and we
can see that
they did not draw their own name right
because we can do a little sandy check
say
one no two three four five right so that
would be
a perfect game where no one drew their
own
uh their own name right
so we checked that and one thing that's
kind of cool is we can just convert this
to a as.numeric right because they're
logical they're essentially zeros and
ones
and since they're all falses uh they're
all zeros
and what i think we're going to do is
since we have to basically check if
if all of them are false we can just say
some some of it
right and if they're all false it has to
be zero
so then we can just say is equal to zero
and that's
true right so this right here is
essentially the game that we did
um so what we can do now is just put
this into a function
so let's actually create this so so
let's just say um
try to replicate the process
using sampling without replacement
uh replace mints and then
say um
check i'll say check
if people through
their own names so i'm just gonna say
right there
right and i'll say uh
count how many times a person
uh how many p how many times how many
people
drew their own name
and then we could just say that
and say check if no one
drew their own name
right so it kind of just went through
the process where we said first let's
just replicate the sampling
right then we say check if they drew
their own names then we see count how
many people actually do their own name
then check to see if no one actually do
their own name or we're saying it's
equal to zero
and now let's actually create this into
a function uh since they're exchanging
books i'm gonna call this a book
exchange i'll write a function right
here
and there's gonna be no inputs because
we're essentially gonna replicate the
entire process
uh we're gonna put this right here
uh we're gonna check if it's equal to
[Music]
uh
gonna check if it's equal to uh their
own
name if they drew their own names and
then we're gonna summit
[Music]
as.numeric
and then we check if it's zero
right so i could actually i should
probably just put it like that
and then put this thing
right there but they're the same thing
cool
so right here is our book exchange and
we're gonna
we're gonna rotate it once twice three
times
etc so i could use
a for loop for this you know just do a
4i
in and then just repeat that put it in a
list
and call it a day um but what's cool
about ours they actually have a bunch of
functions where we can basically
replicate this function thousands of
times so i'm going to say
convert create
a function to use as
a simulation okay
and that function is actually replicate
uh
um and this will basically say like
given how many times you want to
uh use this function which is n so let's
say 100
in our and then our function will be
book exchange
oops
book exchange it just right and now we
have it
replicating a hundred times and we have
all this
right so we have it uh um we have
our values one thing we can do is we can
convert these to as dot numeric again so
now there's zeros and ones
where zero is uh that they
uh what was it that they uh did not draw
their own name
and then we can just say like uh mean
right
so what's the problem that they won't
draw their own name uh or what's
technically the problem that they do
they do draw their own name is point
four
and then you could just say like uh
minus one or the complement of it right
and it'd be a point six
this is obviously probably not the right
answer because we've only done 100 times
but what we can do is actually uh
simulate it multiple times so i'll just
say
sim and we'll just simulate this like
one one two three one two three
like a million times
and then we get our sim so we can just
subtract it
and we can see that the probability that
uh
no one will draw their own name is
63.319
okay so that's pretty straight forward
um but how can we do this in like a tidy
way right
so let's actually do this in a tidy way
first and with the tidy way
what i kind of like about the tideway
even though we're sacrificing
essentially
speed um what we're getting is basically
legibility
and we can do more sani checks so let's
actually do that
one of the things that david robinson
does is he uses crossing
in this case we can say like trials is
equal to one over a hundred
and we can also say that um we also want
to basically simulate these people well
let's just call it i guess
maybe uh draws is equal to one to five
right
so we have that um what we can actually
do now is just
group by our trials
right mutate and then what we're
basically going to replicate
is the the rolling process or the the
sampling process
so just say um let's call it a res so
res
is equal to a sample five
size is equal to five replace is equal
to false
right and now we can see with our trials
we have one
like three one four five two one three
two four five
right so we're just basically simulating
the same thing
okay what we can also do now is we can
say
um we can kind of just do another logic
so we can say like
uh re or drew own
name is equal to uh draws
is equal to res right it's right there
okay and technically if i wanted to make
this a little bit faster
i could ungroup it and then mutate it so
mutate
so mutate uh draws uh i mean drew
own name is equal to draws is equal to
res
right and then what we can do is count
our trials
so for each simulation we'll count
how many people drew own name
right and then what we can say is uh
maybe even do a pivot wider so names
from equals uh drew own name
values from n values
bill is equal to zero
uh values name pivot
oh it's about that
all right so we're saying like count uh
how many people drew their own name
and then we're gonna convert convert
that cell up to a wide format
um and we're saying okay in this case
five people did not draw their own name
which means that is a success uh
in this case one person had to draw
their own name so what we can do now
is actually just do a count where we
could say like count
uh was it um count
false is equal to five
right and then we can say so we're
basically doing a filter account or
like a countif then we say mutate n
is equal to n divided by some m and now
we have our proportions right
um which if we see right now it's point
seven
point three it's it seems like it's
matching up with our probabilities
now what we can do is actually stimulate
simulated like say like i don't know a
million times
it's going to take a little bit longer
than our other um
our other function but let's see if it
actually matches
right so 63.4 63.3
basically what we're expecting is that
we have a 63 chance
of us and not drawing any of our own
names
so that was basically it for this video
i know this is pretty quick and
it's essentially just using sampling but
i think
this type of weekly um question is kind
of a good thing to um
kind of work on uh with addition to like
we're analyzing tiny tuesday data sets
because
it allows you to do a lot more problem
solving with a goal
and you have to do a bunch of logic
stuff like that and i think it's pretty
fun
uh so hopefully i might have got
hopefully got the answer right and i
didn't uh
misunderstand the question but it still
teaches you a lot of how to do like some
optimization in your code
how you do how you would approach um
the logic and kind of write it out in r
it's pretty fun stuff
um so i hope you guys enjoyed this video
and i'll see you guys next week and tidy
on